in this video we'll talk about
alcaptainuria which is a genetic and
metabolic disorder
so alcaptainuria is a rare autosomal
recessive metabolic disorder caused by a
deficiency in the enzyme homogenetic
acid oxidase or agao
homogenetic acid oxidase is an enzyme
that converts homogenetic acid into
methyl acetoacetate so basically this
enzyme catabolize the homogeneousic acid
eventually the methyl acetoacetate is
channeled into other pathways
so this particular enzyme is encoded by
the gene AGD
and in cases of mutation in this Gene
the enzyme production is advocated
when the there is a deficiency in this
enzyme obviously homogenetic acid cannot
be catabolized properly
and that leads to accumulation of
homogenetic acid in the body and this is
the key cause of alcaptainuria
so let's see what happens when
homogenetic acid builds up it can
eventually be excreted in the urine and
that can lead to a pigmented color in
the urine so the urine becomes dark
brown or black
it can be also seen as a stained black
stain on the diapers of babies which
which has a alcaptainuria
then it can also get deposited into
specific tissues like the white part of
your eyes Clara and in the ears it is
also visible the black spot and these
are known as okronosis
when it comes to inheritance of the AGD
gene mutations it's autosomal recessive
that means if both the parents are
carrier means one allele has the
mutation then there is kind of like 25
percent of the chance that the Next
Generation would be affected by this
particular disorder and there is also a
chance that there would be several
carriers in the Next Generation
let's talk about the clinical
presentation of alcaptainuria so
obviously urine color is one of the key
deterministic determinate stick a
feature of alcaptainuria then okronosis
that means Progressive deposition of AGA
in connective tissues which lead to this
kind of like bluish blackish appearance
in the cartilage sclera or in the skin
that which is also known as acronosis is
a prominent feature of alcaptainuria
also AGA crystals can be accumulated in
the joints leading to arthritis and
there could be also AGA crystals
deposited on hard valves creating
cardiac problems
so the complications of alcaptainuria
involves arthritis which lead to Joint
deformities and eventually movement
difficulties or disabilities
cardiovascular valve dysfunction that
might require surgical intervention in
near future
and obviously okronus is in the eye
especially sclera or in the cornea can
lead to eye complications and visual
problems
when it comes to diagnosis of
alcaptainuria it can be diagnosed by
simply looking at the urine color
also doing an simple assay from a plasma
or urine to monitor the activity of
homogeneousic acid oxidase activity so
this is determined from the urine sample
or the plasma sample and lastly which is
rare but generating testing is also
confirmatory test for this kind of
disease
so looking at the AGD gene mutation is
one of the key way to nail the
conclusion that the patient is affected
with alcaptainuria
so when it comes to treatment of
alcaptainuria you cannot really treat
this disease because it's a genetic
disorder but it can be managed for
example the diet could be modified if
the diet has low protein and has
proteins which doesn't have that much of
tyrosine or phenylanine that means it
won't be broken down into homogeneousic
acid so tyrosine or phenylalanine
metabolism pathway leads to homogenetic
acid production
so if those elements are not there in
the diet you would end up producing less
of these metabol metabolic intermediates
then there is also something known as
native Stone which inhibits the enzyme
Upstream of AGA formation
so ultimately to reduce the AGA
production itself
and then there could be symptomatic
management there could be pain due to
this kind of deposition of AGA in
several regions so overall managing the
pain and managing the symptom is another
mode of treatment in this case
so I hope this was useful get notes and
flashcards in our Facebook page or
Instagram all the links are provided in
the description you can support our
Channel using super thanks see you in
next video